on va amener stéphanie accès en fauteuil
roulant sur la plate forme ici on va
attacher les pieds dans les les
plateformes de force donc les deux
harnais pour les pieds puis on voit
aussi la suspendre avec leur lait pour
le corps ici pour la mer de boue puis
ensuite elle
ensuite l'on va relever la plateforme
puis on va pouvoir initier
l'entraînement la marche va avec c'est à
nous aussi on va mettre des électrodes
sur ses jambes aujourd'hui pour faire
contracter ces monsieurs que j'allais
pouvoir vendre et mu qui comptera qu'au
bon moment du cycle de marche donc qu'un
doit mettre du poids sur sa jambe est
clair qu'il ya de spécial s'est
contracté de la machine va faire
contracter sont cadrées mais en fait ça
garde le muscle 5
donc quand on est paralysée souvent aidé
la grèce qui va se déposer dans les
faits musculaire puis certaines
universités musculaire doit être
justement remplacé par la grèce mais ça
permet de garder les muscles 5 et de
réduire le risque de maladies
cardiovasculaires dans le cost et à nous
aussi ça fait la mise en chanson ces
gens donc les muscles contracte plus en
plus sur les autres puis quand on est
paralysé des membres inférieurs et à
haut risque d'ostéoporose
donc le fait qu'elle soit debout et que
ses muscles travaillent aussi c'est
comme si un marché comme si comme vous
et moi donc ça peut permettre de
résoudre des chances de stopper rose une
justement maladies cardiovasculaires sa
garde les articulations sienne parce que
ça fait une contraction aussi
ça fait bouger les articulations